elle pourrait devenir la deux chevaux la
plus chère de l'histoire une dodoche en
bois va être vendue aux enchères ce
week-end au Château d'Artigny l'oeuvre
d'un menuisier ébéniste à la retraite
installé à Sennevières près de Loches le
résultat de longues heures de travail
pour en faire un véhicule unique et qui
roule évidemment démonstration avec
Laura Chauvet
c'est la fin d'une histoire d'amour
entre Michel Robillard et salle de
chevaux une voiture qu'il considère
comme son quatrième enfant j'ai eu trois
fils c'est peut-être ma fille pour moi
c'est une création de de presque une vie
je pensais pas faire une voiture
exceptionnelle et aujourd'hui on me dit
c'est pas une voiture c'est une œuvre
d'art
donc c'est une satisfaction personnelle
en 2011 c'est par passion que ce
menuisier ébéniste à la retraite se
lance dans la construction d'une deux
chevaux en bois un véhicule unique au
monde qui fait sa première sortie dans
les rues de Loches 6 ans plus tard
cette voiture mythique est le fruit de
5000 heures de travail noyé pommier
Poirier merisier elle a été réalisée
avec plusieurs essences de bois
fruitiers dimanche elle sera vendue aux
enchères il faut se replonger et se dire
que ça fait 150 ans qu'on a pas fait de
voiture en bois les premières
automobiles elles sont faites par des
Charrons par les gens qui fabriquaient
des carrosses des choses qui étaient en
bois on a arrêté parce qu'il y avait des
problèmes de sécurité et donc la Michel
Robillard réinvente une démarche
ancienne sur une des voitures qui ont
des mythes de l'automobile française une
voiture qui symbolise à elle seule la
France La Deux Chevaux voilà pourquoi
c'est exceptionnel le prix de départ est
fixé à 150000 euros l'objectif battre le
record du monde pour une de chevaux qui
est de 176000 euros